Đại biểu Quốc hội cho rằng chính xác miệng phía xác cho qua chỉ phát way đầy đủ ý nghĩa nhân văn khi được chìa
khai đồng bộ không tạo trình lệng lệng giữa các vùng miệng.
Tại phíanh thảo luận về giáo dục và đào tạo thuộc kỳ họp thứ mới,
Quốc hội hội hóa mởi lâm nhiều đại biểu nánh giá cao mục tiêu khoản thành việc
cùng cấp xác cho qua miệng phía cho học sinh trên toàn quốc bảo năm 2018.
Tuy nhiên, dự thảo miệng quốc, cho phép các nhiều phương có điều kiện, chìa hai từ năm
hồng trong 2 mi sảo, 2 mi hồng trong 2 mi bệng khiến một số đại biểu ban quan về khả năng tạo ra
sự khác miệng trong thời điểm thu hưởng chính xác.
Đại biểu ma thịt thủy tuyên quan cho rằng quy định liệu phương có điều kiện
dễ dẫn tới các hiểu khác nhau, thậm chí tạo dư luận sò sánh nếu tiêu tiêu chỉ
của thế. Trong bối cảnh trên lại kinh tế xác hội giữa các vùng còn lớn,
việc một số địa phương được chìa khai sớm có thể anh hưởng tới tính công bằng mà chủ trường
tối, nhiều ý kiến đe nghị cơ quan sản thảo, quan thiện quy định theo hướng ui tiền hỗ trợ trước
cho vùng đặc biệt khó khăn miệng lối, 2 đảo và vùng đồng bảo sinh tập thiêu số.
Đồng thời cần xe dụp thiêu chi gió rằng để sắc định điều phương đủ điều kiện,
gắn với năng lực nân sách và khả năng quy đặc nguồn lực sả hội.
Các đại biểu cũng kiến nghi, Thí điểm mô hình thư viện xác sảo qua dùng chung,
tự năm hành hình không chăm hai miếng sấu, qua đó góc phần giảm chí vị và tạo bước chuẩn bị cho việc thực hiện chính sách trên phạm vi bản quốc.